الخيرسون اذا الغارقه في الظلام الى كيا
في الان التي تقف على اعتاب ظلام وشتاء
قاسم فالعاصمه التي بقي فيها ثلاثه ملايين
نسمه قد تشهد في ايه لحظه انقطاعا كليا
لتيار الكهربائي وبالتالي لا يكون هناك
ماء او صرف صحي المدينه تكافح للحفاظ على
شبكات الكهرباء التي تضررت بشده جراء
الصواريخ الروسيه لكن اذا بقي الحال على
ما هو عليه بالنسبه للهجمات التي تستهدف
البنيه التحتيه للطاقه فعلى الاوكرانيين
الاستعداد للسيناريو اسوء هذا الشتاء
السلطات وضعت خطوطنا لاخلاق كيف من سكانها
اذا تلقت انذارا من انهيار شبكه الكهرباء
وتوقف الخدمات كما تجهز المدينه الفالجا
للتدفئه يمكنها ايضا حمايه المدنيين من
الصواريخ الروسيه ومعظمها داخل منشات
تعليميه لم تحدد مواقع مواقع
تمشي صوت
هذا لكن لنكن صادقين اعدائنا يبدلون قصار
جهدهم لكي تكون المدينه من دون تدفئه
وكهرباء وامدادات المياه وبشكل عام يريدون
منا جميعا ان نموت هذه هي مهمتهم يعتمد
هذا على مدى قدرتنا على الصمود وعلى مدى
استعدادنا لسنر يوهات مختلفه يعتمد مستقبل
بلدنا ومستقبل كل مواطن على مستوى
الاستعداد لذا يجب ان نكون مستعدين